[Music]  hello  dr gordon i want to play a game  your aim is to kill adam you have until  six on the clock  to do it  the newspaper started calling him the  jigsaw killer  looks like our friend jigsaw likes to  book himself front row seats to his own  sick little  you can be games one who put me in this  room  we're gonna have to work together if we  want to get out of here  what is it there's a man in my room  most people are so ungrateful to be  alive  [Music]  to overcome something you have to  understand what a perfect engine it is  he doesn't want us to cut through our  chains he wants us to cut through our  feet  bastard yes i'm sick officer  there's a way out of here  we're out of time  live or die make your choice  [Music]  you